I came to next to a patch of black ice
on a cold sidewalk somewhere in downtown
New Haven I was drunk I didn't know
where I was and felt completely lost the
only thing I need to do in that moment
was to sit there and start crying those
nights were all too common for me in my
early years of college the thing that I
most remember about that time was that I
just couldn't sit with myself I was
scared in addition to the normal angst
of being a teenager I was coming to
terms of the fact that I was attracted
to men I wanted things to be different I
wanted to be different and so I turned
to whatever I could to get away alcohol
drugs and my favorite and most
acceptable distraction work but no
matter what I did
inevitably I would come back to myself
just as I had that night in New Haven I
woke up the next morning with the
concerned face of a nurse hovering over
me in Yale New Haven Hospital when my
beam caught wind of the fact that I
drank myself into a hospital bed he
immediately summoned me into his office
I was terrified I thought that I'd blown
this once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to
go to Yale and that I was about to be in
a lot of trouble and yet when I walked
into his office that day he greeted me
with a big smile and a hug and he just
started asking me questions today I know
that he could sense the deep existential
angst that I was feeling at the time and
he recommended two books for me
one was a Christian inspired book called
traveling mercies the other was a
Buddhist inspired book called yoga and
the quest for the true self as I cared
those two books outside of his office
Tiffany he coyly said hey Vince you
might want to check out Church as well
life is hard sometimes we are find
ourselves in situations where we are
absolutely overwhelmed by the demands of
reality where we can't cope where the
only thing you want to do is crawl out
of our own skin or crawl underneath a
rock somewhere where do we turn when we
hit the black ice when we fall how do we
pick ourselves back up for many the
answer is religion but for me at the
time that would have been quite a leap
you see my religion during high school
was the anti religion I was a
card-carrying atheist and I loved
proving it to people around campus in
fact I remember one afternoon I got into
a fight with three Christian friends and
managed to bring all three of them to
tears as I poked cold holes of logic in
their Christian faith now I can't say
that I'm proud of the hurt that I caused
my peers that day but I can say that I
do understand some of the angst that I
felt towards religion at the time after
all I'd been brought up in a strict
Catholic upbringing and had experienced
some of the most hurtful aspects of
organized religion when I was in school
I would get physically whipped for not
being able to recite pieces of Scripture
or certain prayers when the first signs
of my attraction to men started to
bubble up I went under the worst type of
ridicule for my friends in school and a
much more subtle though no less hurtful
form of repression at home
all grounded in the deep religious
conviction that being gay was wrong and
that I was broken yes those tears that
afternoon in high school
those were my revenge against religious
zealot Ori and yet here I was pouring
again over Buddhist texts and Christian
scripture and actually starting to go to
church again you see the pain that I was
in at the time that feeling of
dislocation of alienation from myself
was even worse than the pain that
religion had inflicted upon me it felt
as if my whole world was just swirling
around me and I just needed something
steady to grab on to but if I was going
to go down that path again I was going
to do it on my terms
instead of adhering to any one type of
religious system or dogma I decided to
cast a wide net and began a spiritual
journey that took me from Christianity
to Zen Buddhism to Native American
animism and even the rationalism of
Enlightenment thinkers and over the
course of that journey I became a sort
of spiritual omnivore sampling different
pieces and ideas and concepts from these
religious philosophies in order to
construct my own worldview and my own
sense of meaning in the world over the
course of that journey there were three
habits that I noticed that were common
across each one of these philosophies
that helped me pick myself back up and I
hope will be helpful for you regardless
of where you are in your journey
the first is finding purpose in your
experiences seeking out the meaning and
opportunities that can arise from even
the most challenging circumstances in
traveling mercies the book recommended
by my dean she talks about herself as a
child of God
learning to walk on the earth and sea's
each relapse because she's a recovering
alcoholic as an opportunity for her to
get back up stronger than before now
while I couldn't quite subscribe to the
idea of God the Father and me as a child
I did like the idea of that the universe
would put these trials in my way as a
way of testing me
and making me stronger and so the
concept of a spiritual trial was one
that I added to my spiritual plate the
second idea or habit that I saw was
developing practices that help you honor
that purpose my first yoga instructor
was a woman named Maureen orange
straight out of the 60s
she was actually married to Michael
Bolton for a while rest in peace through
yoga Maureen taught me how to listen to
the body the language of my body and
emotions and taught me the power of
breath to keep myself grounded in
challenging situations instead of
running in the way that I had in the
past away from these types of stressors
today thanks to people like Maureen I
can hold myself in these moments and
share space even a time like today when
I'm pretty nervous as you can imagine so
that was a physical practice I added to
my plate as well
the final habit that I saw is that of
building community my friend Eliza and I
met in a Haitian dance class shaking our
booties which by the way is another
really fun spiritual practice and they
should try sometimes and since then
Eliza and I have continued to laugh
dance and cry together Eliza is the type
of spiritual body that I wish everybody
had when I fall she helps pick me up
when things are going alright she holds
me accountable and isn't afraid to call
me out on things
in an increasingly secular society with
all that's going on in the increasing
stress and chaos that we find ourselves
in it's more and more important for us
to know where to turn in those moments
of duress and yet as we have an
increasingly diverse and wide array of
spiritual philosophies the illness is
increasingly on us to make sense of our
own worldview and to make our own
meaning out of life over the course of
my journey I learned to put my faith in
three habits the question I leave with
you today is where you'll put your faith
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]